bruno daroux merci d'être avec nous que
penser de la déclaration du président
américain joe biden d'une invasion
imminente
bah ça veut dire ça confirme que les
américains et les européens aussi
d'ailleurs ne crois pas ce que raconte
la russie puisque la russie depuis
plusieurs jours affirme qu'elle a entamé
un début de retrait de ses troupes qui
sont massés autour de l'ukraine voilà on
le voit là ses troupes russes basés y
compris d'ailleurs les troupes en crimée
la russie montre des images de convois
de blindés de chars de véhicules
mais visiblement les américains n'ont
pas la réponse à la question d'où
partent ces convois ou vont-ils et donc
suppose que ce sont des images de
propagande et joe biden va plus loin
puisqu'il affirme que la russie loin de
procéder à un début de retrait à
renforcer ses effectifs il parle de 7000
effectifs supplémentaires donc là on est
clairement dans une guerre
informationnelle entre moscou et
washington
on ne sait plus qui croire mais toujours
est il que les deux n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord et que finalement la
méfiance est de plus en plus grande on
avait cru un moment une un début de
désescalade avec cette ces premières
annonces de moscou et puis finalement
maintenant c'est comme toutes les
annonces de moscou concernant ce début
de retrait tombe à plat
ça ne fait au contraire que qu'accentuer
presque la tension est ce que le kremlin
peut intervenir militairement en ukraine
à ce qu'une intervention ça va pas
renforcer justement le sentiment
national ukrainien oui certainement
alors oui le kremlin est en mesure
aujourd'hui logistiquement
opérationnellement de déclencher une
invasion de l'ukraine c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les occidentaux sont si
alarmiste ou une des difficultés si ce
scénario se réaliser ce serait
effectivement
que la tension orchestrée par vladimir
poutine depuis des semaines maintenant a
fortement accentué le sentiment national
ukrainien l'armée ukrainienne est en
état d' alerte beaucoup de civils
ukrainien font des exercices
on a eu cette fameuse journée de l'unité
il y à 48 heures qui a plutôt bien
marché donc oui à l'exception évidemment
du dombass qui est aux mains des
séparatistes pro-russes il y a un fort
sentiment national ukrainien alors après
la la crainte des occidentaux c'est que
tout ça se déroule peut-être dans le
donbass justement puisque on y lit a eu
donc des échanges de tirs là encore ce
sont des accusations mutuelles dont
difficile de savoir qui a commencé à
tirer qui a répliqué mais les américains
notamment pense que
vladimir poutine
via ses relais parce que pose américain
s'est déroulé les séparatistes pro
russes via ses relais sur place va faut
monter un scénario qui fera que les
ukrainiens attaqueront les séparatistes
et donc à ce moment-là l'armée russe
interviendrait non pas pour faire une
invasion serait pas une invasion mais
pour venir au secours de ces
séparatistes d'autant plus s'il faut pas
oublier non plus que la douma a lancé un
appel à vladimir poutine à reconnaître
l'indépendance is la l'indépendance
pardon de ses de ces deux républiques
donc voilà on en est là la situation
reste extrêmement volatiles notamment
dans le donbass et ça vraiment qu'il
faut surveiller dans les heures les
jours à venir et parallèlement c'est la
drôle de situation que nous vivons les
occidentaux disent mais nous on veut
bien discuter sérieusement avec les
russes les russes disent qu'ils n'y sont
pas opposés les occidentaux disent
discuter donc sérieusement ce qui veut
dire que il estime la demande de moscou
concernant l'otan totalement irréaliste
d'attendre même de la guerre froide dit
la ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères
mais par contre sur l' équilibre global
de sécurité sur le pouce sur le vieux
continent si les rues sont prêts à
discuter sérieusement là on peut avancer
merci beaucoup bruno daroux pour votre
analyse